What's up film trivia fans?!
Here's another video for those of you who
love to shock your friends with you intricate
knowledge of cinema?
You might know Tom Hanks' rap from Big off
by heart, perhaps you know which year every
movie in the Halloween franchise was released,
and you might even know what Marvel Studios
were thinking when they gave the go-ahead
for that version of the Mandarin in Iron Man
3, but what about all that lesser known movie
trivia from behind the scenes?There are a
lot of facts about movies that might just
take you by surprise - and that's what this
video is all about.
Here's our latest edition of twenty rapid
fire behind the scenes movie facts...
Warcraft
A live action concept trailer for the Warcraft
movie was shown at Comic-Con back in 2013,
showing a knight fighting with an Orc.
Only a few hours later, it was revealed to
the crowds that the film hadn't even started
pre-production.
Suicide Squad
Within 3 weeks of its releasee, the teaser-trailer
for Suicide Squad had amassed more online
views than both of the Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice trailers.
Suicide Squad
Cara Delevingne auditioned for her role as
Enchantress in Suicide Squad by reading for
Martha from Edward Albee's play "Who's Afraid
Of Virginia Woolf?"
She was asked to read the part in several
different ways, in order to reflect the sorceress
character's split personality.
Suicide Squad
Jared Leto's Joker will use a gold-plated
ivory-handled AK-47 rifle in Suicide Squad.
This weapon was previously seen in another
of director David Ayer's movies, End of Watch,
in 2012.
Suicide Squad
To prepare for his role as Killer Croc in
Suicide Squad, Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje's
research included reading comic books starring
the character, observing actual crocodiles,
and reading up on cannibalism.
Zoolander 2
The teaser trailer for Zoolander 2 was not
narrated by Stephen Hawking, as many believe
it was.
It was narrated using a DECtalk machine, just
like the one Hawking uses.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story
Disney were reportedly unsatisfied with the
first cut of Rogue One, with a source stating
that it had "fallen short of what J.J. Abrams
did with Star Wars: Episode VII -The Force
Awakens.”
Four weeks of reshoots in the summer of 2016
were ordered as a result.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story
Rogue One will be the first live action "Star
Wars" spin-off film to appear in U.S. theaters.
1984's The Ewok Adventure and 1985's Ewoks:
The Battle for Endor were only released theatrically
in Europe and other territories.
Justice League
It's now known that Steppenwolf will be the
main villain in the upcoming Justice League
movie, but the actor for the role hasn't been
cast yet.
However, it is rumoured that Warner Brothers
want either Charles Dance or Colin Farrell
for the part.
The Jungle Book
The release date of the 2016 reboot of The
Jungle Book was April the 8th in India.
This was a week before its release in the
U.S. and was done to pay tribute to the Indian
environment of the film and original novel.
Spider-Man: Homecoming
Although Spider-Man: Homecoming is set to
feature a scene involving a traditional school
homecoming scene, the title is also the same
as a 1984 Spider-Man comic that featured the
Venom symbiote for the first time - this could
mean the villain will be featured in some
way.
Thor: Ragnarok
Tessa Thompson will play Valkyrie AKA Brunnhilde
- Thor's new love interest - in Thor: Ragnarok.
In the comic books, the character leads the
Valkyrior - a group of warrior goddesses who
comb battlefields to pick which of the fallen
are worthy of entering Valhalla, so you can
be certain there will be a lot of deaths in
the movie.
Avengers: Infinity War
The Avengers: Infinity War movies will be
the first Russo Brothers films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to not have a score composed
by Henry Jackman, after the composer previously
worked with the directors on Captain America:
The Winter Soldier and Captain America: Civil
War.
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
Although it is set in the Harry Potter universe,
the American wizarding community in Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them don't use the
word "Muggles" to refer to non-magic people,
but instead use their own word - "No-maj",
which is short for "no magic".
Max Steel
Before Ana Villafañe got the part of Sofia
Martinez in Max Steel, two actresses called
Skyler - Skyler Samuels and Skyler Day - were
screen-tested for the role.
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies
Pride and Prejudice and Zombies was the second
movie reinterpreting Jane Austen's "Pride
and Prejudice" in which Sally Phillips has
appeared.
She previously appeared in Bridget Jones's
Diary, whose source material also was a reinterpretation
of Austen's classic novel.
Jason Bourne
2016 will mark the first time in which a Bourne
movie - in this case Jason Bourne - will be
released in a year that a solo Spider-Man
movie wasn't released.
Although, notably, Spider-Man did appear in
Captain America: Civil War earlier in the
year.
Ghostbusters
In some of the posters for 2016's Ghostbusters
reboot - specifically the ones featuring Kate
Mckinnon's Jillian Holtzmann - on her proton
pack there is the number 2206, which is the
same number as Dana Barrett's apartment in
the original Ghostbusters movie.
Zootopia
These days, Disney's animated feature movies
tend to be accompanied by a short film, but
2016's Zootopia is the first to not be accompanied
by one since Tangled in 2010.
Finding Dory
In the Spanish-dubbed version of Finding Dory
that was screened in Mexico, the voice of
the intercom at the Marine Life Institute
is performed by Dr. Rodolfo Neri Vela - an
actual Mexican scientist and astronaut who
has worked with NASA.
Thanks for watching our latest list of 20
shocking movie facts you don't know.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great movie facts do you know
of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.